allein in diesem sommer gab es hier in
deutschland bisher schon drei
hitzewellen in den nächsten tagen soll
es so weitergehen laut dem deutschen
wetterdienst gilt die warnstufe 2 und
sogar ein neuer temperaturrekord könnte
gebrochen werden laut kliem expertinnen
und experten sind diese hitzewellen
alles andere als normal klar ist für den
menschlichen körper bedeutet das
erhebliche vorsicht diese hitze kann
tödlich sein klingt zum science fiction
jetzt täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen in dieser
woche könnte tatsächlich der rekord
gebrochen werden der deutsche
wetterdienst geht davon aus dass im
laufe der woche die 40 grad marke
geknackt werden könnte
denn das hoch yvonne bringt extrem heiße
sahara luft nach deutschland innerhalb
von vier wochen wird es damit an manchen
orten in deutschland zum vierten mal
mehrere tage lang sehr heiß heißer als
normal donnerstag könnte der heißeste
tag der woche werden hier werden
temperaturen von bis zu 41 grad celsius
erwartet und zwar im raum köln im
moorgebiet im rhein main gebiet und im
saarland der historische hitze rekord
seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen vor
140 jahren liegt in deutschland bislang
bei 40 3 grad gemessen wurde dieser
rekord temperatur im sommer 2015 in
kitzingen der deutsche wetterdienst sagt
zu den prognosen für die kommenden tage
wenn diese vorhersagen eintreffen würde
diese hitzewelle in die geschichtsbücher
eingehen
dabei gab es in diesem jahr bereits um
den 26 juni herum eine erste hitzewelle
die zweite folgte ende juni mit einem
maximum von 38,9 grad celsius und anfang
juli folgte dann eine dritte hitzewelle
zumindest im südwesten deutschlands klar
ist in den kommenden tagen werden wir
wohl auch nachts kaum mit erholung
rechnen können unter fachleuten ist von
so genannten tropennächten die rede
denn die temperaturen sinken auch nachts
nicht unter 20 grad celsius dazu andreas
matz arag ist der leiter des zentrums
für medizin meteorologische forschung
des deutschen wetterdienstes dwd in den
folgenden tagen werden die menschen in
manchen teilen deutschlands mit der
warnstufe zwei leben müssen das bedeutet
das vor allem den tag über eine enorme
wärmebelastung herrscht und die
sogenannte gefühlte temperatur über 39
grad celsius liegt eine extreme
wärmebelastung bedeutet aber nicht nur
dass die lufttemperatur hoch ist
dann auch der wasserdampfgehalt der luft
und die strahlung den menschlichen
körper zu setzen natürlich hat der
menschliche organismus verschiedene
mittel um gegen die hitze anzugehen
auch wenn die wärmeeinwirkung zu groß
wird bricht das kühlsystem zusammen
gefährdet sind dann vor allem ältere
menschen und kleine kinder denn die
physiologischen mechanismen um den
körper zu kühlen sind bei senioren
eingeschränkt und bei baby so
neugeborenen und kleinkindern noch nicht
richtig ausgebildet zudem haben babys
und kleinkinder im verhältnis eben zu
ihrem volumen eine viel größere
oberfläche
das macht das nötige temperatur
management schwieriger aber auch bei
gesunden menschen mittleren alters kommt
das körpereigene kühlsystem in solchen
zeiten möglich an seine grenzen
sensoren auf der menschlichen haut und
im inneren des körpers messen die
temperatur und werden in unserem gehirn
abgeglichen ist die umgebungstemperatur
stark erhöht droht eine überhitzung dann
muss der körper maßnahmen einleiten um
sich zu kühlen zunächst werden die
blutgefäße erweitert um die abgabe von
wärme an die umgebung zu maximieren doch
das hat folgen denn dadurch werden die
organe weniger durchblutet
beispielsweise die skelett muskeln und
so fühlen wir uns träge und schlapp die
verminderte durchblutung des namens kann
durchfall zur folge haben reicht diese
erhöhte hautdurchblutung nicht aus
beginnt der körper an zu schwitzen das
ist wirklich der wirkungsvollste
mechanismus um eine überhitzung zu
verhindern denn durch die verdunstung
des schweißes gibt der körper wärme
energie ab und kühlt sich ab
ein normal trainierter erwachsener kann
pro stunde etwa zwei liter schweiß
abgeben manche sportler kommen sogar auf
vier liter um den körper weiter auf
touren zu halten und ihnen die
nährstoffe wieder zuzuführen
die er durch das schwitzen verliert
müssen wir trinken und essen andernfalls
droht eine gefährliche dehydrierung und
muskelkrämpfe wenn die relative
luftfeuchtigkeit aber über 75 beträgt
kann der schweiß auf der haut nicht mehr
verdunsten dann droht ein hitzestau im
körper menschen die der prallen sonne
ausgesetzt sind und keinen kopfschutz
tragen bringen auch er hirngewebe und
ihre hirnhaut in gefahr
stichwort sonnenstich das ist eine
thermische irritation des gehirns die
schwindel übelkeit und eine störung des
bewusstseins mit sich bringen kann bei
sehr großer hitze
aber auch ein hitzekollaps eine
stressreaktion des körpers denn die
organe brauchen mehr sauerstoff die
folge das herz kreislauf system muss
richtig ranklotzen und es kommt zu
herzrasen ein hitzschlag entwickelt sich
wenn das körpereigene kühlsystem
zusammen bricht der körper ist dann akut
überhitzt die kerntemperatur steigt auf
mehr als 40 grad an dann kann das gehirn
anschwellen und es drohen bleibende
schäden und im schlimmsten fall auch der
tod übrigens gibt es keine offizielle
definition des begriffs hitzewelle
doch natürlich sind damit zeiten gemeint
in denen es mehrere tage lang
hintereinander deutlich wärmer ist als
im durchschnitt und das ist wirklich
sehr gefährlich für viele viele menschen
es gibt viele zehntausende tote in
solchen fällen laut dem klimaforscher
mojib latif aus kiel hat sich die zahl
dieser hitzewellen seit 1980 mindestens
verdoppelt und teil sogar verdreifacht
die zahl ist inzwischen sehr hoch sagt
er
eine folge des klimawandels darüber
hatten wir hier bei pixum science
fiction er schon berichtet dass kann
solche ereignisse können jetzt dem
klimawandel mit einer entsprechenden
wahrscheinlichkeit zugeordnet werden und
nicht nur in deutschland ist in den
nächsten tagen das große schwitzen
angesagt denn die hitze soll sich über
weite teile europas ausbreiten
in den usa wurden bereits am wochenende
neue hitzerekorde aufgestellt es wurden
temperaturen von mehr als 43 grad
celsius gemessen und für die bevölkerung
in städten wird es noch schlimmer
darüber habe ich ein video bei pixum
nature gemacht werden städte weltweit
zur hitze fallen anklicken anschauen und
clixoom nature abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran